Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Emma Gon
Usted preguntará por qué dormimos,
o cuándo dormimos, o cuánto dormimos,
o cómo dormimos.
Lo bueno es que la ciencia tiene
respuestas a todas estas preguntas
y es sorprendentemente simple.
La respuesta de la ciencia a por qué,
cómo, cuándo, cuánto dormimos
es muy fácil:
ni idea.
(Risas)
Momentito.
¿Los científicos no saben algo tan obvio
como lo que nos pasa todas las noches
o nos debiera pasar todas las noches?
No, no lo sabemos.
Eso es maravilloso.
En cierta forma nos convierte
a todos nosotros en científicos.
Todos podemos hacer
experimentos con nuestro sueño,
el de la persona que tenemos al lado,
el de nuestros amigos, nuestra familia...
Eso también es hacer ciencia.
Bueno, no es tan "ni idea",
algunas cosas sabemos.
Por ejemplo, por qué dormimos.
Eso parece bastante obvio: uno duerme
porque tiene sueño, está cansado.
¿Es tan obvio?
A ver, piensen un cachito:
cuando están de vacaciones,
que no están cansados, no hacen nada...
¿Duermen muchos menos?
No.
Y cuando hacen mucho ejercicio, tienen
una tarea muy demandante desde lo físico,
¿duermen mucho más? No.
Con lo cual no es solamente
estar cansado, algo de eso hay.
Pero debe haber más cosas
al por qué dormimos.
Algo sabemos: que dormir es importante.
Hace muchos años, se hacían experimentos
en los cuales se deprivaba a animales
de sueño, no se los dejaba dormir.
¿Y saben lo que les pasaba?
Se morían.
Y se morían en dos semanas,
como si no comieran.
Dormir es vital,
es tan importante como comer.
¿Y qué más pasa en el sueño?
Un montón de cosas:
crecemos, el cuerpo se repara,
se recuperan energías.
Un montón de cosas que
si no durmiéramos, no ocurrirían.
Se consolidan las memorias.
Lo peor que pueden hacer
si tienen un examen o algo importante,
es no dormir [por estudiar]
porque seguro les va a ir mal.
Así que del por qué
sabemos algo, pero no del todo.
¿Qué pasa con el "cuándo"?
¿Cuándo dormimos?
Nosotros evolucionamos
como bichos diurnos,
tenemos que estar activos de día
y dormir de noche,
guardarnos en la cueva,
alejados de los peligros,
alejados de eso que
está pasando allá afuera.
¿Y por qué es eso?
Porque tenemos un pedacito de cerebro
que mide el tiempo y le dice
al cuerpo qué hora es.
Es el reloj biológico.
En cierta forma, somos relojes con patas.
Todo lo que hacemos ocurre en el tiempo,
no solamente en el espacio.
Dormir también ocurre en el tiempo.
Ocurre o debiera ocurrir de noche.
Pero cada vez está pasando menos eso,
estamos robándole horas a la noche
para ganar en la vigilia.
Desde la invención de la luz eléctrica,
ese gran ladrón de sueño,
cada vez nos vamos más y más tarde.
Nuestro cuerpo no está preparado para eso.
De hecho, es cierto que hay gente
con más necesidades o menos de dormir,
o dormir más temprano o más tarde.
Hay gente más matutina,
en la jerga los llamamos "alondras".
Algunos de Uds. la están pasando
muy bien en este horario,
otros son los "búhos", más vespertinos,
que todavía están bastante somnolientos:
"¿de qué se trata?, ¿dónde estoy?".
(Risas)
De hecho, hasta hay personas muy
pero muy matutinas, los alondras extremos,
y personas muy pero muy
vespertinas, los búhos extremos.
Puede llegar a pasar, cada tanto,
que un alondra extremo conozca
a un búho extremo y se casen.
(Risas)
En ese caso, los hijos son un milagro.
Pero hay que escuchar a ese reloj
que nos dice cuándo hacer las cosas:
cuándo estar despiertos, cuándo dormir.
A veces entra en conflicto
con la realidad, con la sociedad,
con el horario del trabajo, del colegio.
Por ejemplo, los adolescentes
son típicos búhos
y hacen todo mucho más tarde.
Uno piensa que es cultural,
se van a cualquier hora,
chatean hasta cualquier hora
con sus amigos, salen muy tarde.
Hay mucho de cultural,
pero esa cultura se monta
sobre la necesidad biológica de que
el reloj les dice "hace todo más tarde".
¿Cuál es el problema?
Al día siguiente,
¿el colegio a qué hora empieza?
A las siete y pico de la mañana,
lo cual es absurdo:
los pibes están dormidos,
literalmente dormidos
en las primeras horas.
Tenemos que trabajar sobre esto:
escuchar al reloj y también
que la sociedad escuche al reloj.
¿Y el "cuánto"?
¿Cuánto dormimos?
¿Cuánto tenemos que dormir?
Si llevo a cualquier de ustedes,
o a cualquier persona
al laboratorio del sueño
y les digo: "Duerman lo que tengan ganas",
el promedio de la gente adulta
es de ocho horas, veinte minutos,
ocho horas y media.
A ver, ¿dormimos ocho horas y media?
No.
Dormimos bastante menos.
Se calcula que estamos durmiendo
una hora menos que hace 50 años,
y unas dos horas menos que hace 100 años.
Eso es mucho, realmente es mucho.
De esas horas ya nos estamos robando
unas dos horas de sueño.
Es más, podríamos
hacer una proyección, ¿no?
Si dormimos dos horas menos
que hace 100 años
y una hora menos que hace 50 años,
si hacemos la recta y la seguimos,
más o menos para el año 2758
no dormimos más.
(Risas)
Eso no puede pasar
porque el sueño es una necesidad.
Pero la necesidad
también es de horas de sueño.
Y eso es para los adultos.
Los adolescentes debieran
dormir nueve horas o más;
los chicos, entre nueve y diez horas,
y tampoco las están durmiendo.
Por muchos motivos,
el principal es social.
La sociedad está comprimiendo las horas
de sueño y nos trae problemas eso.
Las pantallas también nos perjudican
porque la luz que sale de las pantallas
--y nadie duerme solo últimamente,
todos dormimos con una pantalla
en la cama, por las dudas--
es una luz que le dice
al reloj que es de día,
por lo tanto, le dice "despertate,
está todo bien, seguí de largo".
Claro, al día siguiente
hay que despertarse.
Dormimos menos,
dormimos mal, dormimos poco.
"¿Y cuál es el problema?",
uno se preguntará.
"Yo estoy fenómeno, en todo caso,
recupero el fin de semana.
¿Cuál es el problema de no dormir bien?".
Un montón de problemas.
Uno de los problemas es
que vamos a estar somnolientos.
Claramente, vamos a estar
con mucho sueño durante el día.
Uno podría pensar: "No es grave,
me duermo una siesta".
Vamos a estar de mal humor.
El no dormir nos cambia el estado de ánimo
y eso es lo menos grave.
El estar somnolientos o de mal humor
no es tan grave como enfermarnos.
No dormir es sinónimo de enfermedad.
En principio, nos vamos
a enfermar de más infecciones.
El sistema inmune necesita dormir para
protegernos de lo que está ahí afuera.
Pero también nos vamos a enfermar
de trastornos metabólicos.
Nos vamos a enfermar de diabetes.
Cuando esto es crónico,
cuando la deprivación de sueño
es crónica, aparecen las enfermedades.
Por lo tanto, no dormir no es
solamente un problema individual,
empieza a ser un problema
de salud pública el sueño.
Y todos tenemos
que ser conscientes de esto.
Seguro que ustedes oyeron hablar
de un concepto que es el de "jet lag".
El jet lag es lo que
ocurre cuando uno vuela.
Atravesás husos horarios,
llegás a destino.
Para el mundo es una hora,
para vos es otra.
Y estás medio zombi unos días hasta
que te acomodás con ese nuevo horario.
Si viajás por turismo no es nada grave,
pero si viajás por trabajo,
la cosa puede ser complicada.
El asunto es que uno puede tener
jet lag sin moverse de su casa.
Cuando el horario de la sociedad es
distinto del horario que tenés acá dentro,
tenés lo que se llama "jet lag social".
Y todos tenemos jet lag social:
todos nos despertamos con una alarma.
Por lo tanto, no nos estamos despertando
en el momento que
nuestro reloj biológico lo dice.
Es más, podría ocurrir
un jet lag social bastante más grave.
Imaginensé que vuelan de acá
a África y se quedan una semana.
De África vuelan a Asia
y se quedan una semana.
Y de acá... Sonamos porque
me quedó en medio del Pacífico...
Vuelan a la Isla de Pascua
y se quedan una semana y vuelven.
Bastante chiflado hacer eso, ¿no?
Eso es lo que hacen los trabajadores
que están en turnos de trabajo rotativos.
Una semana trabajan de día,
otra de tarde, otra de noche.
Como si estuvieran volando
alrededor del mundo todo el tiempo.
Y obviamente se enferman
de lo mismo que dijimos antes:
de trastornos metabólicos,
trastornos cardiovasculares
y, además, la OMS,
la Organización Mundial de la Salud,
puso al trabajo en turnos rotativos
como un factor en riesgo para el cáncer,
Así que dormir mal, dormir
a deshoras no es cualquier cosa
y hay que prestar atención.
Nosotros investigamos
esto en el laboratorio.
Investigamos cuándo dormimos,
cuánto dormimos,
porque necesitamos datos,
necesitamos evidencia
para después volcarla a la sociedad.
También estudiamos
qué pasa con esos chicos
que tienen que levantarse
tan temprano para ir al colegio.
Y nuestra secreta esperanza
es de retrasar un cachito
el horario de inicio de las clases.
Se imaginan, cada vez que decimos
esto en la escuela, somos héroes.
También investigamos qué pasa
con nuestros trabajadores
de turnos rotativos
para ver cómo mejorar
su calidad de vida.
¿Y por qué hacemos todo esto?
En principio, porque lo que
hacemos en el laboratorio...
en algún momento
ojalá llegue a esa sociedad.
Además, porque es lo que soñamos.
Nosotros soñamos con un reloj
que ande bien, que esté adaptado al mundo,
que no nos enferme.
Y, como todo el mundo,
queremos cumplir con nuestros sueños.
¿Quién no quiere cumplir con sus sueños?
Pero para cumplir con sus sueños,
hay que empezar por algo bastante obvio:
soñarlos.
Y para soñar ¿qué hay que hacer?
Dormir.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)